[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'était jour de grand oral
pour eux face au monde à de
l'agriculture ils sont clairement tous
claqué et puis je crois bien aussi
viollet et n'en sait pas sur quoi
alléger la fiscalité des transmissions
avec la défisc
quatre qu'elle peuvent être bien ses
objectifs à seissan à ces grands sur
transposition c'est le choix de sophie
sire que vous ne pouvez pas pour
l'ancien président si pour les uns
partie on soutient la laissez moi qui
peinait à autrement mois je m'en vais
franchement tu passes ton temps un
message aux français
on a bien
fait mais au lieu de se contenter des
pouliches content d'aller chercher
confidence j'ai pas tari l'oscar du
lapsus riante à fabien roussel depuis
six mois ils nous bassinent
quotidiennement avec la bonne viande le
bon vin la bonne bière ce matin c'était
la fois de trop moi quand je dis que je
défends la gastronomie française une
bonne viande un bon vin un bon fromage
mais aussi une bonne vieille une bonne
bière
[Applaudissements]
ceux du nord c'est le choix de sophie
leblanc 2 pourquoi pas at il quand même
je terminerais chez moi
le mec il est méchant j'ai les larmes
aux yeux parce que comportement de grève
on fait trop de l'apec eric et moi
depuis quatre ans aimerait bien tous les
deux c'est quand même dingue une hormone
avec une longue histoire mais là ça y
est c'est la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder un moment donné ok semble
logique mais on est pour que l'industrie
pharmaceutique ce soit une industrie
s'adjuge 3 et laissez-moi répondre s'il
vous plaît c'est quand même pas possible
de faire comme ça donc je réponds non
mais non mais on ne peut pas articuler
on peut pas raisonner dans les choses
que vous posez là son contenu et de
préciser je ne je suis en train de
partir je suis en train de voir ce soit
dans l'air voilà entre nous dans vous
affolez pas vous n'êtes pas obligé d
éducation à tous mais n'en ai pas voulu
me laisser parler d'eux trois minutes
y'a pas de soucis c'est moi la série
donc merci du si pour cette question
jean luc mélenchon c'est quoi c'est
purement pour qu'on puisse donner la
parole en oeuvre de l'accord non mais
attendez ce 1.2 compliqué on va répondre
en deux secondes
ou la bouche des dites moi ça me
laissera du temps
[Applaudissements]
les gros mots sont bons pour la santé ça
c'est très bonne nouvelle vous avez un
gros mot préférée à pauline j'en ai
plein j'aime bien les combes et on ne
dit pas ça on la joue parce que c'est
des gros mots bon en tout cas d'après
cette étude réalisée par des chercheurs
anglais c'est important de jurés de
prononcer des gros mots ça aurait
beaucoup de bienfaits pour la santé
mentale et physique premier avantage du
gros mot ça fait du bien quand on en a
marre aime beaucoup de bien en cas de
douleur voilà il faut jurer ça fait
baisser la douleur faut les gars vous
venez voir là on arrive au maire
allez
on y va c'est super
je viens d comme une saucisse regarde et
on est pas mal moi j'aime bien tiens si
on relève james on l'enlève
très bien mais il est délicat alors bon
bah ça c'est très bien les gros mots
permettra aussi d'avoir plus confiance
en soi de prendre plus de risques les
gens qui n'en utilisent pas prendrait
plus de précautions dans la vie selon
les chercheurs ont par exemple il faut
prononcer des gros mots avant une prise
de parole ou un événement stressant par
exemple en entretien d'embauché vous
lâcher une dizaine de gros mots avant
évidemment ça vous détendre entrée dans
la salle des essais comme toutes les
bonnes choses les gros mots faut pas en
abuser les chercheurs recommandent 60
grossièreté par jour pas plus vas-y
vas-y vas-y vite
hop
[Musique]